c'est un parc qui revient de loin
abandonnée il ya trois ans le domaine
était en friche en une année de temps
les jardins à l'anglais zale italienne
puis tous les autres et enfin le jardin
à la française sont revenus à la vie
tous les sens des gens doivent être mis
en éveil dans ce jardin
c'était vraiment l'idée fondamentale
donc on a une structure visuel qui est
hyper importante et intéressante
on a une structure au niveau de tous les
jets d'eau qui nous permet d'avoir
toujours un bruissement toujours quelque
chose qui nous rappelle la nature et
également au niveau des senteurs avec
tous les rosiers toutes les plantes
vivaces qui aussi exalte certaines
chanteur donc on a tous les sens comme
sade mis en éveil c'est vraiment je
pense le thème principal de jeunes
en 2014 un couple en recherche d'un
petit coin de nature pas trop lent de
paris a littéralement craqué pour ce
domaine de 5 hectares et son manoir du
xviiie siècle
c'est un mélange entre la raison et la
folie c'est la folie qui l'a emporté à
la base on n'est pas des spécialistes ni
des passionnés de jardin on a découvert
le lieu le manoir est ravissant un
charme fou et les jardins juste
exceptionnel et quand on la visite est
la première fois on est littéralement
tombé amoureux du lieu
une centaines d'essences d'arbres et
arbustes 300 variétés de plantes
composent cet ensemble
le tout entretenu le plus simplement du
monde on travaille sur la phéromone pour
les limaces et puis le bacillus qu'on
peut pulvériser
donc c'est un champignon qu'on peut
pulvériser sur sur les plantes pour
faire un fongicide ou insecticides
donc on a on a des des moyens naturels
les jardins du grand courte oiseaux sont
ouvert tous les après midi sauf le mardi
une flânerie idéal pour les amoureux
romantiques